let's talk about everything that's been
happening for you it's been
pretty incredible how are you feeling
these days
i'm feeling definitely way better than
last year
like i'll get into that but i was going
through a little bit but
now that i'm starting to see like like
my potential again and
like that like yeah that i'm loved it's
like
i love it so it's like it's putting me
on a really good path
for sure that's great what was going on
last year that
i mean obviously there was the pandemic
and everything that was happening but
what separates this year from last year
for you
i think last year i was just dwelling on
the fact
that i'm not playing hockey anymore
i got to work construction like i was
just kind of like
you know and i didn't really want to do
that like my dad's in construction and
stuff
so yeah i was just kind of dwelling but
then this year is when i kind of just
accepted the fact like
you know what just be a normal guy work
and yeah just take it simple and then
that's yeah so i started feeling better
this year after that yeah i think it's i
think that's a common feeling from
everybody
just trying to figure out you know where
we fit
where do we belong what are we doing and
it seems to me that you've
definitely found where you belong
because the sort of reaction that is
that is you know everywhere online right
now tell us a little bit about
um how this all started how did
did your tick tock account go from this
to this
yeah so it started
two years ago when kovitz started i was
just making them for fun when i was
bored
and last year i ended up kind of hitting
like a big
uh like i got like it was like in two
weeks i gained like 500 000 followers
this was last year last summer and then
and then it plateaued a bit at 500k
so in the winter that's when i just kind
of just stopped making tick tocks i was
like
i just lost interest a little bit and
i guess i lost like the fun in it like
thought i was like getting famous kind
of lost the fun
but and then starting work again this
summer
is when i found the fun back in it me my
dad started going for walks he was
showing me like
these like oldies and stuff and i saw i
just started playing them for fun and
then yeah i gained an older
crowd which has been so supportive
because
yeah they've been sending it out
everywhere they've
contacted you like so they're giving me
a lot of opportunities
and it's awesome i was my dms were
blowing up
being like you need to talk to this guy
he brings so much joy
and so much happiness i mean you talk
about it a little bit
that you're sort of you've reached a
demographic
um that is a little bit older you know
of the that love the 80s nostalgia and
that kind of music
um talk about why did you pick that
genre of music
yeah i didn't really like pick it i just
kind of played one song
i forget what song it is right now
either oh mandy
into the night it's one of those songs
but i played it
and yeah they loved my vibe in it and
i don't know like that music's just like
i like it better it's more like love and
touches your heart so it's like
so yeah i started playing that and then
they just my fans started loving when i
was playing those old
videos so i just kept doing it and now
it's like kind of like my thing like
whitey's bringing everyone back to the
80s
so it's like
i mean you have over 1 million followers
19 million likes on tick tock
um was your intention to to become a
tick tock star when you started all of
this
like not really like i just but i
i kind of knew like tick tock could open
up doors so i was like
and i always wanted to be something like
maybe an actor or a model or something
like
i was just a big dreamer as a kid i
wanted to make the nhl at first now i
want to be a bathroom
you know so and then
but yeah so
now it's like i didn't really expect it
but now i'm at 1.5 million and it's like
just kind of keep trying to get better
every day now
that's amazing you're known for lip
singing a lot of retro songs did barry
manilow's
well you did barryman alone song mandy
he gave you a shout out and reposted it
on instagram how does that feel
that was unreal i i never knew barry
like before but
um like my parents were going nuts about
it they're like do you understand that's
very manly
i'm like what about john fogerty how did
that collaboration happen that was
pretty wild
i know right like
same thing never really i didn't know
who john ford was but i knew the center
field song
so i was like right when he messaged me
to collab i just started listening that
song over and over i was so pumped about
it
but yeah he reached out to my agency and
said we should get a video
put together and then so yeah he pretty
much
all i did was make a couple videos he
made his part and then
his agency um combined it both videos
made it like a collaboration and
now me and john are kind of buddies like
he
had a good skype call and it was nice
yeah that's so good
you talked about your mom and dad what
do they think about this i mean listen
it is an older demographic we're all
drawn to your videos what's your mom
say that's what i want to know my
yeah like my biological mom i haven't
talked to her yet
um right before all this happened we got
in a little argument so i haven't talked
to her in a little bit
i'm gonna reach out to the administrator
but my stepmom has been very supportive
through all this like
she's doing all my finances and thank
god
it was perfect timing yeah it's perfect
timing too because
she's like finance like ceo and like
i need that help right now so she's
helping you you know it worked perfect
and yeah and yeah she's just your dad
think about all this my dad
he's he's a little starstruck himself
like he's like buddy i knew
like you could be something and stuff
and so he's like really like pumped up
and but i love it because like
he's like he won't he's a little star
himself my dad but
just never got noticed so he's a really
good guy he went through his stuff
but i'm just happy he's happy for me and
he's really nervous though but
i'm calming him down and telling let's
just take it step by step
yeah just day by day absolutely so
who were you most surprised that has
connected with your content
is there a star is there a musician is
there another
influencer is there a tv host
like anybody that you're just like what
yeah you were definitely a big hit but
a really big hit was definitely little
heidi and addison ray when they followed
me
they're you know them yeah i do yeah
they're big tick tockers so when they
followed me i was just like
in shock i'm like i actually have
potential now it just pumped me up you
know i was like
are you gonna do a collab with them
could you um
yeah i always say i believe so like um
i'm thanks to shout out to my agency
mode models for helping me out and kelly
strait
they uh got i'm not gonna say exactly
who it is but i'm signing with some big
agencies in the states and
yeah hopefully i can collab with addison
and little huddy i believe so
it'll happen amazing so where would you
like to see all this listen
i've interviewed brad pitt george
clooney
all the bigs oprah's the like just
everyone
um and you could really take this
anywhere when i talk to your fans
they're so excited about you where would
you like to see
all of this go when you said brad pitt
that kind of got me
pumped up i love to be like that one day
like a brad pitt
um but yeah just
i don't know like there's so many doors
i want to open like
it's like i want to be like i want to
maybe be a mo
like a big model or a big actor one day
but i don't know like i want to do it
like just something that
i can be myself and people can like
learn from me and respect me and love me
so like anything that's big like i'll be
a
prime minister one day if i could like
anything
that's your plan that's that's listen i
did not expect that
you you shocked me for sure that was
that's a good one prime minister
so brad pitt prime minister i feel like
those are those are good goals
for sure yeah that's it yes um do you
have anything to say to your
to your followers uh who you know got
you on this show
and are helping you move right along
what do you have to say to everyone
i just want to say i can't thank you
enough because you literally helped me
through like
depression and i'm just happy that i can
help you guys through
things too i've seen a lot of videos of
people going through their own thing
and me helping them out so i just love
that i can do that and i
hope i can just keep doing that i'm
going to keep being myself being real
and
yeah just thank you so much can't thank
you enough literally can you give them
the wink
someone asked me to ask if you can give
them the wink
oh there it is
you